when you're doing this breath work
eventually what happens
is um you start to usually
start to feel some mix of emotions
i've ranged from feeling like i'm on
some sort of psychedelic and having
visions
to screaming to crying to laughing to
almost orgasming
and it's very much based on whatever
you're
holding in your body and it's different
every single time
so you're never done because you can use
it anytime you want to move energy
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that
happen i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the pretty intense podcast is
shalina
ayana she is the creator of the rising
woman account on instagram that has oh
you know 1.8 million followers
her content is so beautiful so deep so
introspective
so evolved you know i really wanted to
tap into
to that information that she has to go
deeper into
you know understanding her perspective
in an expanded way about conscious
relationships and
of course then her own experiences as to
how she arrived at
understanding even what a conscious
relationship was through
you know stories and about her past that
aren't so pretty
things that she had to learn lessons she
had to learn red flags
and you know she then explains so much
about just you know how we operate as
human beings and connect with each other
and and really get give ourselves an
opportunity to
really live this full like full love
embodied life
if you have any level of curiosity for
expanding
your awareness to what causes
triggers what causes projection
the difficulties and relationships that
we that we all face
really does a very good job of
explaining it check out this episode
right now
and follow her on instagram and the
growing
will be inevitable you said that color
is really important to you
and your page would say that aesthetics
and color
and balance is really important because
it is so
um calming and the the logo
is so it's so cool yet so pretty yet so
simple and um and of course i'm only
just speaking about the visual of it
but the content of it is
like nothing i've really ever seen it
when i first started
following your page rising woman um
i just honestly i was just learning so
much so
let me just say thank you thank you for
your vulnerability for your honesty
for sharing and um
it's to me it's it's uh
it's a place for us to learn and grow
and we're all flawed and we all face
challenges
and it's about learning what those are
and how to deal with them
so what brought you to the place where
you
maybe even backing up from this from the
from the page because how long has your
instagram account been
going gosh i think
really we started getting going in 2018
so i i started rising women in like
2015.
i had the idea for years before that and
i wasn't really ready i there was just a
lot that i had to go through i think
i had this desire to connect with women
and
to help them heal through certain things
and i had been through some of those
things but i think there was just more
to go and so
in 2018 i had started running women's
groups with my co-facilitator heather
and we were just doing an amazing job
together as a team
and so at that point we sort of sat down
and we're like okay maybe we should
combine our skill sets here and and
partner and so
at that point that's when we started to
grow and then over
a year's time just sort of expanded
and since then we've hit over a million
followers in just such a short amount of
time it's amazing yeah it's really
mind-blowing how quickly it all happened
it's uh it's so impressive and for i i
didn't even lay the groundwork for the
page if anyone doesn't follow it but
it's
it's about consciousness it's about
relationships it's about
um sel the working on the self and the
dynamics that we
deal with personally as well as the ones
we bring into a relationship
so it's all very very much about oh
consciousness and awareness
and if you don't follow you should
definitely follow it because it's so
um you it's just so much to learn
um so when did you become uh
when did you start to realize that this
information was in you or even that
that sort of like was there a moment
where you hit an evolutionary
point a breaking point perhaps
yeah i think it's always been in me
ever since i was really little like
i started dreaming really intensely when
i was about two
like i can remember my first dreams
because i i would go out of body every
single night
and it got to the point where it was so
intense that i
was really struggling with it when i was
really little
and so i had a lot of capacity i think
in the dream world really young and it
really scared me and so i think i just
shut it down
um and then i grew up in and out of
foster homes and i
my mom was mentally ill and very
depressed
she was just 22 and she had me and had a
lot of trauma
and i never met my father so how my life
path went was that i was
just sort of figuring it out as i went
and really kind of
acting out my own generational trauma
and ended up in a lot of really sort of
scary situations
and abusive situations and when i was 19
i ended up in a really abusive
relationship
um which i i now see as sort of like the
catalyst for my awakening in a way
there was at one point where he had
hurt me and i was in the bathroom
i had locked myself in the bathroom and
i looked in the mirror
and i could hardly recognize myself but
all of a sudden it was as if
the top of my head opened up and just
this message poured in and it was just
like
shalina you're going to be speaking on
stage to women about this one day like
this is what you're meant to be doing
and i saw myself doing that and i
remember actually telling him that i
said
you know i had this vision the other day
that i'm actually going to work with
women who
were in abusive relationships or you
know were in harmful places in their
lives
and and this is part of my path so i
think you should really get help
because um this is going to be talked
about
and i think it was a year and a half ago
where i
first spoke on stage about that exact
moment wow and it was really full circle
for me
so i sort of got that download really
early and then i still had to go through
all this other stuff and mess up a lot
in my relationships and
be on both sides of it you could say so
i feel like i've just been gathering
that wisdom
and then when i was 25-ish
i got married to somebody who was from
another country
and we were best friends and i was like
okay well
we don't really want to be together long
term but even if we don't
stay together like i want you to be able
to be here
and uh so you know being a naive in
20-something we we got married and then
that all fell apart it was
very much ended in deep deep betrayal
towards me
and um i lost everything in that process
everything all my money my business my
reputation like everything i was just
torn apart but there was a really
beautiful
thing that happened in that which was
all of the pain i was feeling i was also
getting all these flashbacks of my
childhood or
memories of things that i kind of
thought i had worked through where i was
like oh wow this is not dealt with at
all and so i had this moment of
realization like all of this stuff that
i'm feeling
it actually doesn't have anything to do
with him like i don't need him to do
anything i don't need him to come back
i don't need him to fix it i don't even
need him to stop doing what he's doing
i just need to go get right with me and
my inner child and so then i
met a spiritual teacher and then i
worked with him for four and a half
years in
transpersonal therapy course in miracles
jungian shadow work
and depth psychology so that was sort of
the catalyst so it's all been it's all
kind of come from
a lot of pain um but it really led me to
a beautiful path
so wow what are some of the biggest
like what was the first big thing that
you worked through the first big
emotional
um barrier that you worked through the
abandonment moon for me
was a big one and the funny thing is is
i learned so much about myself in that
20 year old stage
because this partner and i we
was this the abusive one no this was
just so after
the abusive partnership i left that
partnership and i went off and had a
whole bunch of other wild experiences
lots of learning there's stories for
another day to move on to
just i mean that's not always the
easiest thing i think there's a lot of
issues that arise with that where it
makes it they can make it feel like your
fault and
so there's a lot of bravery just in that
one
that one action so thank you good for
you yeah and i'm grateful that i had the
capacity to because i think
you know i didn't have children um there
were a lot of opportunities that allowed
me to get out of that and not everybody
has those opportunities and
and that's something that i'd love to
see shift um
so yeah so now this guy he he was just
um a great guy he was a nice guy
nicer than anyone else i'd ever dated
given my history so i was like oh he's
nice
um and so you know i thought oh i've you
know i got into chakras and crystals and
so i'm healed and so
here now i've met this guy and whatever
let's do this happily ever after
totally and it was very surface level
spirituality i hadn't actually done any
shadow work i hadn't looked at any of my
wounds and and so it turns out he was
actually just um
someone there who's meant to trigger my
deepest wounds and leave me
in shambles so that i could grow and i'm
grateful for that
um but what i what i realized when
when it all happened was for about a
year or two leading up
there were so many moments where i had
actually said to him you know i actually
don't really want to be in this and
i had this naive idea that he needed me
because i was sort of in this caretaker
role
in our relationship and i i think my ego
was
just way ahead of itself thinking like
i'm needed here and this is very
codependent dynamic
and so at one point i actually wished
i remember he went away and i was laying
in bed and i was looking at the ceiling
and i was like i hope
he just falls in love with somebody else
so that they can take care of him and i
won't have to feel bad for
breaking up with him and then he ended
up he did he
within a month or two of that he wow he
um ended up in love with somebody else
and he left
and the interesting thing was is that
this person who i didn't even want to be
with all of a sudden i was just
desperate for him
ah why do you why do you think that
happened well the abandonment wound was
so
alive in that moment and that's the
thing is the abandonment wound is what
keeps us going back to these toxic
relationships or just relationships that
don't serve us
or people who really aren't in alignment
for us because
that part of us that is so afraid to be
abandoned
again just gets activated when someone
rejects us or leaves even if they're not
right
and so we really have to kind of heal
that in order to be able to make healthy
decisions and say yes to the right
things no to the wrong things
so it was really interesting for me to
observe this almost like feeling of
total out of control
craziness inside of myself where i felt
so desperate for him to come back all of
a sudden and i was so shattered
um and then i really realized like oh
this is my inner
child and it makes total sense that i'd
be feeling this way because when i was
three i actually was
physically abandoned and um and so i
need to go do that work now
um and so and so i did so even though
like all of that
stuff happened where um you know the
behaviors and the things that he did
were really not okay the way that it
ended
uh i'm still really grateful for it
because i feel like i wouldn't even be
able to be
here now in the marriage that i'm in at
all
self-aware without having that kind of
thrown in my face
so why why is it that
what we fear most we attract
right like uh you fear that you're going
to be abandoned so you find someone that
abandons you you fear that
you're not enough so you find someone
that doesn't really want you
you you know what whatever it is that
your
core trauma you man why
help me i know why i don't get it like
if we don't want it why do we attract it
it's such a good question and i think we
all ask that question all of the time
and
something to know is that consciously
we don't want that but unconsciously we
don't even know that the fear is there a
lot of us
right right we get to a certain point in
our self-awareness and our healing work
where we're like oh okay
i have this fear but until then we're
just acting out
so there's a lot of armoring that
happens when we've been hurt especially
when we're little so we have all of this
protection
and so we're actually kind of operating
from this place
of self-protection and all of the things
that we're doing
is signaling that we're actually not
ready for the type of partnership we say
we want
right so we're unconsciously pushing
love away we're defending
we're controlling we're hiding we're
leaning in too hard we're doing all of
the things that say
you know i'm actually still engaged in
that old pattern i haven't actually
shifted
so just saying that we want a conscious
partnership isn't really enough we
actually have to
embody it and and that takes a lot of
time
the other thing is is that i personally
believe
that our souls come here to grow and
that we're here
to learn something and it's maybe it's
predetermined maybe it's not i kind of
feel that our path
is predetermined in a way like a soul
karma where
you come here with a specific lesson to
learn
and the people you meet um even though
you know they're narcissists or they're
jerks or they do
awful things and of course that's not
okay and
when i've left those situations i have
had an opportunity to wake up
in myself and i think if we are able to
use
our painful experiences as catalysts
then
we can get where we want to be which is
in a healthier place
so we have to sort of be with those
parts of us that still don't believe
we're lovable
that still feel like i'm actually not
enough and so i'm gonna go find somebody
who mirrors that
back to me unconsciously and
it's familiar maybe it is familiar right
so i just went to
uh the workshop with harville and helen
hendricks um
it's called getting love you want they
wrote many books they're basically my
heroes
and my husband ben and i went up to
eslin institute this weekend
and they talk about how we always
attract our opposite
but we also attract our what they call
the imago
and the imago is essentially the
template of our parents like our
caretakers
and it's usually the most negative
traits that they had
right because that's familiar so um
we'll find somebody who
sort of reminds us of our caretakers in
a way
and the the most negative traits and
unconsciously there's an attempt to heal
that by closing the loop
by changing the story and this teaching
is
ancient as well in more conscious
relationship principles
where we'll attract somebody who
seems the same as our parent or our
caretaker
but we have this idea in our minds that
if i can only
rewrite the story with this person then
i'll be whole and complete
and so then both of our inner childs are
kind of
looking for healing together the problem
is is that
we aren't usually aware of that and both
of us are trying to get our
needs met and they're usually opposite
and so
the healing happens when we both
recognize that and are like okay i'm
gonna actually
i'm gonna do this work with you and
we've become allies
that takes a lot of willingness so is it
possible then to enter into a
relationship
unhealed and are we i guess the question
first question would be are we ever
fully healed yeah
and then the next question would be if
can we at what point in time what point
in time is it safe
to enter into a relationship and trust
that this is a
that this is a conscious enough
relationship and an aware enough
relationship where
we are able to show up for each other in
a way that is
sustainable yeah that's a great question
i probably get that question every
single day
because it's confusing i don't know
personally i don't believe in being
fully healed i think
the human experience is one of fracture
right and
um heartache and suffering and pain
um as well as joy and pleasure is sort
of the light and shadow of the human
experience totally
um and i don't know that it's possible
to ever be
fully healed and i don't think you need
to be in order to be
in relationship in fact i would say most
spiritual teachers would say be in
partnership
to heal because we can think that we've
healed something and then we get into
relationship and all of a sudden all
that stuff comes up again you're like
what the hell i thought i dealt with
this what is going on
and that's the nature of conscious
relationship is
that if i'm in partnership with you
you're going to trigger my deepest
wounds
and then there's an opportunity for us
to go deeper together because i can
always choose to react
and to get defensive and to push love
away and to keep telling that story like
see this was this is what always happens
right like they always do that or people
always leave or they always betray me
and i'll even make it so because it's
such a strong story in my mind
that even if you're extending love to me
i won't be able to receive it
or i can work on softening and i can
lean in a little and i can say
this hurt and this is why and this is
the fear that's coming up for me right
now and here's what i really need
um and harvard hendrix this weekend they
did
specific dialogues for helping couples
connect and share
you know their fears and their needs in
a really loving way
so there's many different processes and
formats but essentially that's the work
is really figuring out where are you
getting in the way
of showing up fully in relationship and
you can be sort of in a
intense healing phase and still be ready
for partnership
if you're willing to own your [ __ ] and
if you're self-aware enough to
say this is mine these are my wounds and
i don't expect you to heal them for me
but here's how you can help i think
where it gets dangerous
is when we're in a frantic state if
we're
really deep in our trauma we're in a
really dark place
and we're feeling desperate for
connection and we're really lonely
that's where we tend to draw in people
who
won't be the best for us because when we
come from desperation we're not
choosing right that's like it's survival
yeah so there's no boundaries when we're
in survival mode
we're just trying to hang on so that's
why i think it's risky
otherwise i'd say that we're all equally
messed up
and it's going to be a lifetime of
learning in relationships so it's
possible to enter in at any point you
can drop in at any point but the
but the most important part is that
you're ready to show up and be honest
so when people have
issues and they they they'll say like i
you know they're having a difficult time
something they're facing
based on my experience i would tell them
like you're so much further along than
you realize because most people stay
asleep
forever and or maybe at least
until it's so much later in their life
till they let go
so what are what relationship is such an
important
topic and something that you address
nearly every time i feel like when i'm
reading
your posts and and the information that
you have to offer
so conscious relationships
is you know the title of that would you
would your conscious relationship
consciously so what what's that
describe like for someone who these are
new words for them this is new
new word pairings right consciousness
and relationship what
so maybe kind of like how do you view a
conscious relationship
yeah so there's a few different ways um
in some of the esoteric teachings that
i've learned conscious relationship is
really about
the relationship to self um harville
hendricks talks about how
conscious relationship is really about
creating safety with your partner
um which i love i think both are true i
think it's about relationship to self
because if our relationship to self
isn't awake then it's really hard to be
awake at all
in in relationship with others because
we're going to get so triggered
and also creating safety is really
really important
and the way that i see it is the only
difference between
what you might want to call like an
unconscious or a conventional
relationship versus a conscious
relationship
is that in a conventional relationship
if you do something to hurt me my first
instinct is to react
to blame you to demonize you
and to put all of the blame on you and
and then to do whatever my coping
mechanism is
sure so okay so that could be trying to
convince you to love me deeper because i
have this wound in me that needs
validation
it could be to ghost you because you
know once you've hurt me you're out
whatever that coping mechanism is that's
where i would deploy it and and i would
continue on the pattern
now in a conscious relationship the only
thing that makes it really different is
that
when you hurt me i'm able to sit with
that and share
what hurt me and set a boundary if
needed and
also look within myself and ask
questions like what does this represent
for me right now what does this feeling
remind me of
is there a time when i was little where
i remember feeling this way
and and then i can go deeper and like
what is the fear underneath that
and then how can i share my need in a
way that you can now meet me
so instead of pushing love away i'm
learning how to work with what's coming
up in me
as a way to bring me closer to you in
relationship and then also for some of
us who
like to use spiritual language you know
closer to god or to source or to higher
power whatever
and that's really it it's can we slow
down enough
to be self-aware in each moment and take
some responsibility
that's it what are how
like how did you become self-aware or
what can someone do if they're like
listening and they're like oh man okay i
guess i want to be self-aware
and where do you start there's many
places to start
the most obvious place is always just
observing your thoughts
you know this is a concept i remember
when i was like 21
i learned about observing my mind or
watching my thoughts i think it was like
tony robbins or something
and i remember just all day walking
around my house doing laundry or
whatever i was doing
observing my mind and
i think that that's the really good
place to start because when you're
watching your mind you can start to
create a little bit of separation
between your thoughts
and your feelings and what's actually
true so
i always like to just watch the stories
that my mind creates or watch the
judgments it creates but not attached to
them
so it's always this dance where you
recognize like you are not your thoughts
and you're also not your feelings you
have thoughts and you have feelings
but that's not who you are and so in
every moment you get a
choice to attach to the thought and ride
it through
and then build on it and create a story
or you can lovingly
question whether or not that's serving
you or not
and especially in relationship i think
that's an important one
because you know in my partnership with
ben you know
we have our challenges like it's hard
it's really hard for me to be in
relationship
and sometimes you know he'll just say
something the wrong way or whatever
and my mind can immediately
catastrophize like oh well
you know he's going to try to control me
and he's you know not looking out for my
best interest you know i just need to
run away from this relationship
and then i can watch myself and i can go
oh wow like my inner child's
really freaking out right now and it
makes sense that i would be freaking out
because
i haven't actually had a history of
being safe
but if i'm gonna slow down enough to
breathe and look at this man and see him
i can trust his intentions and i can
remember okay
this person actually really loves me
he's always doing his best
you know that comes from that place of
feeling safe yes
safety fall back on that to lean into
that and go
this person is here because they want to
be here they love me
they support me um
[Music]
yeah becoming self-aware of those
triggers because it's
one thing to observe your thoughts when
nothing's going on
which is a great first step because it
makes you more aware of being the
observer
i'm starting to read a book called
untethered soul and
and so it's talking about how we aren't
our thoughts like we have
this you know companion in our head
that's constantly
yakking and they're actually are the
meanest person like if we
we would never want to be friends with
that that
that messenger in our head that keeps
yakking all the time and telling us both
sides of the story and what about this
and self-doubt
you wouldn't want to be friends with
that person so
you know how do you uh deal with it
how do you how do you use it how do you
turn it off how do you not listen to it
how do you disconnect from it being your
instead of viewing it as your thoughts
they're like
you know not yours you are the observer
of the thoughts
um but um but being the observer such a
great
way to start off by realizing how much
is going on
and how how to step outside of yourself
and realize that everything that's going
on is not always
that meaningful and it's not always true
and it's not always true
this is where shadow work comes in right
shadow work it's the
aspect of looking at the darker parts of
our minds looking at the darker parts of
our nature the things that we
often push away the things that we
suppress or deny
so for example if i believe that anger
is bad
i'm not going to express my anger i
might shove it down
i might let people walk all over me or i
might only express my anger in explosive
ways
when i'm really pushed because i've
bottled it up so much
and generally that only happens in close
partnerships and this is where we get
those
really volatile explosive relationships
where the conflicts are just off the
charts
and all of this is due to a lack of
ownership
so we're disowning these things in us
that are very human
very normal it's normal to have anger
it's normal to have hate
it's normal to have jealousy all of it
right it's okay to have those things
but in our culture we don't allow those
things very often
especially as women it's like anger no
you're not allowed to be angry it makes
you crazy
so um so there's all these reasons why
we push that stuff down
and when we're able to allow it and give
space to it
instead of it controlling it us what
happens is we're able to
express it in a healthier way we're also
able to see it for what it is in the
moment
right because our shadow or you know our
ego
it's really actually designed to protect
us from perceived threats
the more hurt we've been as young people
as children or in early relationships
the more protection we'll have the
stronger our ego will be
so think about that every time your mind
is defending
every time that there's a story building
instead of looking at it like oh you're
gross too and i don't like you get out
of here
how about bringing some compassion like
oh
you you're feeling really scared right
now it makes sense that you're jumping
in to over protect me
but actually i'm here and i got this
thank you for letting me know
and i i'm here and i'm going to assess
this situation and i think actually we
are safe
and so it becomes this dialogue with
your internal self with your shadow and
your inner child where you can see the
defenses for what they are
which is protection and how beautiful is
it
that inside of you there is protection
and there is this desire to to make sure
that you're safe and you're never hurt
again
but also working with it in a way that
instead of it having you on a leash
walking you around sabotaging your
relationships
you've now you've now trained it almost
like you your cute little fluffy dog and
you're walking it around and so
you go barks with them and you're like
yep thanks ego
yeah i mean the ego is a far more i
think common word for
um people to understand and know
a little bit about um but there's a
it has a bad reputation um
so maybe let's like how is it good
though right because you just said it's
here to protect you and the ego just
wants to
take care of you but it it's really
short-sighted
is the way i feel about it it's like
i'll take care of you right now in this
very moment you'll feel the best i can
make you possibly feel right now we're
not worrying about tomorrow
or the next year um so how do you
like how can you develop a good
relationship
with the ego and use the ego
[Music]
yeah okay so eagle as we said is
self-protection
um it has basically one role
which is to survive nothing else so if
you think about it
um there are a lot of ways that you can
survive
but they often involve removing yourself
from connection
right because what guarantees our
survival in many ways
just cutting ourselves off making sure
that we're right
right making sure that we win making
sure that
nobody can see our vulnerability and so
those are all of the things that prevent
us
actually from being in healthy
relationship aren't they it's we're
always trying to be right we never hear
our partner because
we're never listening right and if we're
always trying to win
then we've now made them our opponent
not our friend
right and so there's all of these ways
that we remove ourselves from love and
so
doing work with our ego and and doing
shadow work which is something that i
did in depth ben and i did it for about
four and a half years in these wow
shadow work containers essentially
like four to eight hours a week in
person
doing really deep shadow work processes
and
in that you really get an opportunity to
see all the ways that you defend
right and the beautiful thing is is that
the more we own it the more it softens
because it's actually when we're
ignoring it or when we're suppressing it
that it takes over so one of the first
ways to work
with the ego rather than try to
obliterate it
is to again observe it to notice it and
to just slow down
a little right take breaks to tune in
and talk with yourself and what is this
really about and
rather than always jumping into reaction
can you slow down and take a breath and
really feel
and not just the defense but what's
beneath that
what's the feeling is are you sad are
you afraid are you afraid to be
abandoned
are you feeling unlovable like what is
that what's going on in there
that's a really big piece and then the
other piece is really just remembering
with that part though i think it's good
to say that there's so many scenarios
where you'll say
you know well what's wrong like what's
really what's going on you're like i'm
just pissed
yeah i'm mad and that's a that's a norm
like that
that people think that they're feeling
right yeah but you're that's not the
deepest layer
so so maybe dive like one more deeper
into you're having a conflict with your
partner and
they say like i'm just pissed off yeah
and you go how do you handle that so it
so there's two sides here so for anyone
who's holding space
if you said i'm just pissed off you know
when i'm what i'm learning is that
mirroring is really important so i could
say
okay i'm hearing that you're pissed off
right now and then we could just
you know take a breath let's just like
be with us for a moment
and and ideally we create a space for
you to be able to share
where i'm not reacting to you like oh
well you're pissed off i'm pissed off
too like get over it or whatever the
thing is where i
i engage right and that's what happens
both people are defending
the the ideal way to approach
a conflict with a partner is to i like
to take a little bit of time
to tune into what it's really about for
me and then you know we sit down in
front of each other and we share like
okay so actually i'm feeling really
angry
i'm feeling really frustrated because
this thing happened
and when that happened it made me feel
sad or it made me feel scared and this
is what my mind did with that
right so an example would be you know
ben and i have had conflicts where
um he snapped at me in some way he
didn't even mean to he just did
you know i dropped something and then he
reacted and then it startled me
um and i remember saying to him you know
when
when that happened i felt really
startled and my nervous system got
really
jarred and then i felt really scared
that i'm going to be in a relationship
with you
and it's going to be really intense all
the time and that i'm going to feel like
i need to protect my nervous system
and then i'm going to pull away and i'm
going to shut down from you and that's
not what our relationship needs
but sometimes i don't feel safe and so
then i'm scared that you know
i'm going to ruin this because i don't
feel safe
and what i really want is to feel
connected to you and what i really need
is for you to be a little bit more
gentle with me
um and when i frame it like that it's
really easy for him makes relationships
sound
really easy you say that i'm like oh
that sounds so easy we'll do that
oh i only do that sometimes other times
i'm a total dick
and that's you and that's the thing
right is i think it's so important to
remember like
any relationship that you see out there
in the instagram world or people who are
like we're in a conscious relationship
uh it is still a normal relationship
with two people who act like children
sometimes and
um our deepest darkest stuff comes out
in relationship
so don't expect for perfection right
don't expect that
um but if in any moment where you or
your partner are feeling something big
and you can say
hey can we just take a moment and i just
want to sit and share my feelings with
you would that be okay
could i just share my feelings with you
if you're feeling a ton of anger
sometimes the good thing to do is just
be like i'm feeling really angry right
now and i need to take a time out
you can go run or scream at a pillow or
you can dance or
sometimes i just go in my room and i cry
and i scream into my pillow and i just
i get to the sadness and then we can
talk
but it's really about being able to
communicate
and share without blocking any of it
you really have to allow yourself to
feel it because the more you bottle it
up the resentment builds
and that's when relationships really
break down
that makes me think about the energetic
body too
and how you know feeling it is not it's
it's
there's a literal feeling associated
with it
and you know what have you learned about
that
i mean that's a it's a powerful tool as
well to
tap into where you feel it and the
energy
centers of our body and also then
where we are holding it and then the
physical manifestations that we have i
don't think that they can be
they can be overlooked in in the world
anymore that we will
manifest problems dis-ease in our body
through
the dis-ease that we have in our lives
and
and and from my experience and
personally
about going through things that have
come up for me that
are very hard and traumatic and they
remind me of old story lines and
relationships or childhood
and how i can manifest that in my body
and what's really frustrating that i
feel in my body before i know it in my
mind which is a bummer but
but sometimes you feel it in your body
after because you've been suppressing
something for so long
but going through the process of
acknowledging it saying it writing it
um looking at it uh you can
clear that from your body but you know
you see there are so many people that
struggle with things whether it's
you know issues with their stomach or
you know
whatever other possible manifestations
are had but the energetic body is
uh is a real tool i remember reading
something that was really nice and it
says that the body
if it shows up if something shows up as
a problem maybe it's a
an illness or something like that that
makes you have to
sort of like look at something how
wonderful is it that our body tells us
we're killing ourselves like we need to
look within
and um there's something something
waiting to be
brought forth have you had any
experiences like that
oh yes so much it's been a huge part of
my journey
um so first of all trauma does
store itself in our body especially if
we have like developmental trauma
then we might have gone our whole lives
feeling
kind of broken i don't want to use that
word as in a literal way but we can feel
broken but we can just assume that
that's the living experience like i've
always struggled with my
health and my energy and you know so
much
childhood trauma burned my adrenals out
before i ever had a chance
to build them and my nervous system
never developed healthfully because
i was always scared and i was always
unsafe
and so before we're seven our brains are
shaped
90 and our nervous systems are wiring um
for how to respond to
certain things like how do i respond to
touch how do i respond to love
how do i respond to a threat how do i
respond to conflict
and for any of us in any stage of our
life if something
intense happens something traumatic our
bodies will hold on and remember that
right they've they've shown that you
know our fascia can
store and release trauma so
i've always found for me that my body
will
act out like i will have pain or i will
have some sort of shutdown
um when i'm feeling really emotional
i used to like get like a patch of acne
on my back every time ben and i would
have an angry fight
and um what i've learned really
is through doing somatic therapy it's um
it's essentially it's called somatic
experiencing and the founder
his name was peter levine he wrote this
book called waking the tiger and many
others
and he has a trauma healing institute
which i highly recommend and there's
somatic experiencing
is really about helping the body move
trauma out of the tissues of the organs
and it's um a facilitated process where
we're really learning how to rewire our
nervous systems
so for many of us we don't realize that
our nervous systems have been damaged
we don't realize that we're actually in
a
state of hyperarousal most of the time
like feeling anxious
um feeling reactive jumpy
not able to calm down fearful
just kind of high frequency
and that's the nervous system being
overactive because somewhere along the
way
something was triggered the nervous
system had to react it overreacted and
then it's kind of stayed there
wow right and so it's exhausting it is
and i've been through that where my
nervous system
was so hyperactive that i could barely
function i was so tired i couldn't
handle light
i couldn't handle sound i was just
kind of in a dark room most of the time
and this is a common experience for
people who have had trauma and they
don't realize it and then they're
diagnosed with like chronic fatigue
immune disorders fibromyalgia all of
these
physical symptoms that actually can
often be addressed through
trauma therapy so in somatic
experiencing
the practitioner will teach you just you
know for sitting in our chair
how to notice things in a room and
really be present in our bodies
but then also they do table work and
it's um
similar to osteopathy if you've ever
done that where they're like adjusting
your organs
except for they're not putting pressure
anywhere
so i'll just like not touching you at
all okay yeah with permission they're
very
very consent based so i'll lay on the
table
and she might put her hand on my arm
like i'm just gonna put my hand on your
arm would that be okay okay
sure puts her hand on my arm and then i
know my whole body
my my legs everything's stiff and
it's not a very strong reaction it's
very subtle so if i'm not really tuned
in i might not even notice i'm doing
that
because my nervous system just does that
but what i noticed is that
it took about three months before she
could put a hand on my arm where my
whole
body wouldn't just kind of go brace a
little wow
and it still it still does because when
we don't get that attachment need met
really early or if we're abused in any
way
then our nervous systems will react even
to good things
and this is where again these defense
mechanisms where why can't i make a
relationship
work well your nervous system is not
ready
for any type of relationship so you
gotta actually
calm that down um and so there's this
process and then eventually they're
working with your organs so like holding
you know just a light touch on the
kidneys or the adrenals
and i could actually feel my kidneys and
my adrenals
unraveling like cramping and releasing
trauma
and literally showing me not everybody
has this experience it's different for
everyone
it's okay if you don't see anything at
all but i would see
the actual defense mechanisms that were
coming out
that were like moving wow so
it's a really powerful way to reprogram
the nervous system and if you're finding
yourself
stuck in a really intense pattern and
relationship that you just
you don't want to behave that way you
don't want to keep doing that thing but
you just
you can't stop even though you notice it
go to the nervous system
yeah is that easy to find
i don't know how easy it is to find
depending on what area you're in what i
know is in my area live in vancouver
in canada there are somatic experiencing
therapists and they're all very busy
um i'm sort of shouting from the
rooftops right now like can anyone in
the healing space go become
a somatic experiencing therapist because
it's so needed
i see it as like the foundation for
healing in some ways because we need to
remap
but if you look up somatic experiencing
therapists or if you look up
i think it's just look up peter levine
his institute will come up and you can
usually find someone
the other cool thing is is that we're
about to hire some somatic therapists
for rising women
and we'll be offering some of those
practices online as well
so you can do this remote yes you won't
be able to do the touch the table work
but there are somatic practices that you
can do
you know just in your own home and
they're very simple and subtle and at
first you're kind of like well why am i
just looking around the room at
objects and saying like i noticed this
book or like i noticed that table and
like i noticed my bum on the chair
but that's actually what it takes for
the nervous system to re-learn how to
calm down
and to just be present well you think
about it we never do that
no i mean we never stop or slow down
enough to go
that's a glass that's a table you have
black boots on
you have long hair there's a microphone
there's a light
like you you just you don't ever slow
down that much
it reminds me of how beneficial even
just something as simple as taking a
breath can be
or even three one can do it though you
can sit here and if we all just
there's no way to do that
and not feel a little better yeah
do you do any breath work what have you
learned about breath work
yeah so when ben and i started we
started doing the conscious relationship
trainings with our teacher
years ago we started doing this practice
called rebirthing
which is actually quite an intense form
of breath work
yeah and it's really this uh you'd be
like this
for like 30 to 40 minutes straight wow
laying on your back
and we call it kind it's kind of
catharsis breath work right with
carthage
it's like you're really having a baby is
it in the kundalini vein
no it's more like they did it in
encounter groups
um you know back in that at eslin and
um you know different therapy groups way
back in the day kind of in
even in like the osho days with like in
those
groups um and and rebirthing has a more
of a history which i'm i'm not doing
service so
you'll have to do your own googling for
that um but essentially it was a breath
work that was designed for
westerners to remove trapped motions in
their body
because we tend to be the ones who
bottle it up and don't feel
so it was designed to move energy
in the body and to help us sort of let
some of that stuff go
and when you're doing this breath work
eventually
what happens is you start to
usually start to feel some mix of
emotions
i've ranged from feeling like i'm on
some sort of psychedelic and having
visions to screaming to crying to
laughing to almost
orgasming and it's very much based on
whatever
you're holding in your body and it's
different every single time
so you're never done because you can use
it anytime you want to move energy
and then the other form of breath work
that my partner is trained in
is breath wave which is a little bit
more gentle and i actually prefer it now
and it's a more gentler breath and so
you move a lot of that energy
instead of through screaming or through
thrashing um through toning
it's like ohming or shaking your body um
and making noise like that um and it
sort of creates a channel
like a cyclical channel where you can
cycle the energy through your body
and it's great for improving your immune
health
for helping you move move stuck emotions
which is again that somatic piece
but it can also it can be triggering for
some people who have really deep trauma
so i always say you know if you have a
lot of trauma
get someone to hold space for you don't
do it alone so that
you have that experience of being
connected and held
yeah yeah well i love that you know you
point out that we can do our greatest
work in partnership
and how there is so much emphasis to
work on the self and you really can't
you really have to show up for yourself
on some level
um primarily before you can show up for
a partner
if you can't show up for yourself you
won't be able to have the moments of
self-reflection where you can say like
okay i realize i'm being triggered
but that you can do the most growth with
a partner
because um because we we all have that
to do
so um that's beautiful like to be with
somebody to be able to share that space
hold that space
but here's the thing there's there's a
lot of times in couples where
one arrives finally at this place where
they're like
i must do something i need to make a
change or they've been
reading or seeing enough information
through
accounts like rising woman or some of
the others that are
expanding our consciousness what if your
partner
is just like what if
how how do you make them how do you open
them up
because we can't push right you can't
make somebody be somebody or
they don't want to be but presuming that
they they they need to start taking like
how can you
lead them down the path that makes them
become self-aware to become
more conscious in a partnership yeah the
short answer
would be you can't because it's their
path and you don't know
what their soul came here to learn
however
what i have found is that if i'm taking
full responsibility for me
and i'm doing my work then
two things can happen one my partner
might actually
shift when i stop taking the energy off
of them and i'm not like
change be different i'm going to fix you
and my healing work is actually
control or i get to a place where
my meats are just never met i don't feel
respected i don't feel safe i don't feel
seen
and there's not willingness and so maybe
this partnership isn't right
right those are just kind of the only
two options so one
option is that you stay entirely focused
on your own work
and that you take full responsibility in
every moment and
see what shifts from that now some
people have argued and said well
no both people have to be 100 willing or
it can't shift
um and there definitely does have to be
willingness
i do think though that when we shift how
we show up sometimes
we don't realize that we were creating
that pattern
right so like with my partner with ben
when we first started dating
i think for a year and a half our
conflicts were very annoying because
we'd get into a conflict and we didn't
deal with it very well and i
would want to work things out right away
mostly because i was anxious
and i was like trying to get him to be
different
so i'd be kind of controlling and he
would just shut down and avoid and he'd
sometimes even leave the house he'd go
out he'd turn his phone off wouldn't
talk to me
and then i'd call him ten times and be
like we gotta work this out
and it got really frustrating and uh so
i labeled him as avoidant and me is
anxious but of course i was the one
doing my work because i'm ready to work
it out he's not so in order for this
pattern to shift
he obviously needs to change because
he's avoidant so he's the one making all
this
happen so we did that for a while
about a year and a half in we sat down
and did a process together and we were
doing a clearing which is a
structured way to talk about your
conflicts
like a discussion yeah yeah so we take
turns and something i want you to know
is and etc and you're taking ownership
and so in that i said to him you know
i'm starting to see
how i'm holding this uh archetype that
you know your brother held when you were
he was bullied by his brother
i said i'm starting to see how when i'm
really intense like that and i'm really
anxious and i'm really like in your face
trying to get you to be different
how i'm representing you know the people
in your childhood who did that
and i understand now why you need space
and
i'm no longer going to do that to you
when we're in conflict
i'm going to ask you once if you're
willing to hold space for me and if
you're not i'm going to go into the
other room and i'm going to feel my
feelings
and uh and so i started doing that and
it was like
two or three times and right away he was
he was coming to me
right away when in conflict and he was
the one approaching me
and it just took that like and and so i
was perpetuating that pattern
but if i had to just said oh he's an
avoidant jerk
who doesn't want to face me in conflict
i made it all
his problem a i was not using empathy i
wasn't seeing what that was about for
him
um and i wasn't growing either because i
was being self-righteous it was all
i was the the one doing the right thing
and he was doing the wrong thing
no growth so for me i sometimes think
yes you can shift the pattern by
shifting yourself
other times you can't and there's no
one two three step formula you can't
guarantee
all you can do is take full
responsibility and heal for you
right because if i heal for me no matter
what happens
i'm safe in myself right and if my
partner
can come with me on that journey even a
little bit if i feel safe and loved with
them
great yeah and if not
build your house and yourselves yes i
am there was a post that you wrote down
you
you posted what being in a conscious
partnership is about and
i i think it's worth reading this and
then i and then i think that
if you could expand on then the other
side of it of what it's not
because i think that as people we're
always like
we're looking i'll look at this anybody
will look at this and go
yes yes no yes and then you'll see the
other side of it which is the what
should a partner not be
and you have to be honest yeah right so
being a conscious partner is seeing your
partner's wounded inner child and
learning how to love them better
so important if you want to expand on
any of these
you're feel free yeah oh that's a good
one for me
i try to practice seeing everyone as a
child i was telling ben this the other
day
like when we're driving down the street
or if i'm going for a walk anyone i see
i just take a moment and i just imagine
them as someone's baby
that's real and it changes how i feel
internally
about everyone in the world and uh it
drops me into my heart and i have
compassion for them in that moment
instead of judging them which is so easy
to just judge people sure
we always think we know why someone's
doing what they're doing or we see them
in their worst moment
in the grocery store and we're like oh
what a dick and
um when i picture them as someone's
child
i soften and seeing my partner in that
way
i'm always invited to nurture him and be
like oh right like when he was little he
didn't get that
yeah and so he's defensive right now
because he really needs that
yeah and so maybe i can just drop my ego
stuff a little bit right now and show up
for that
like you say upright from the heart and
not the head yeah right
which i think is uh when we get to
getting curious rather than defensive
that shows up i see that i mean i i do
see that in in my own relationship
my my curiosity can show up like an
interrogation
yeah and and and it's these are just
dynamics that we work through
you know to maybe i don't show up maybe
i don't deliver it in the best way
tone cadence phrasing body body posture
body language all of those things are
really important when it comes to
trying to communicate with your partner
about something that they might not
really
feel that comfortable around but but the
curiosity
is so important yeah i think curiosity
you know when you mention oh sometimes
my curiosity can be interrogation i can
totally relate to that
because i i've been very good at
psychoanalyzing ben
and i've really had to work on that
because it's not fair and it's not kind
um but when an interrogation is
happening
what are we really doing we're actually
trying to
get them to agree to
our assessment of what they're actually
doing or what their intentions are right
so
we're trying to pin them in our story
we're like my story is that you don't
love me
or my story is that you are being
inconsiderate and that you don't care
about me
so when i'm interrogating you i'm gonna
question you in a way
that is going to try to force you to
agree to that
so that my story of being unlovable can
be true they're the ego wins
how did you know my story because that's
most of our stories my story i'm really
good at that one
but the curiosity is something different
it's it's um harvard hendrickson and
helen
uh they talk about having a wonder
an awe and wonder for your partner so
it'd be more like
what was that like for you right or
um does this remind you of anything you
know when you were little
and oh what was that like for you
oh wow like that must have been really
hard tell me more about that you know
they they always they mention um asking
is there more about that a lot
so rather than um trying to pin them
somewhere you're just
letting your partner share and you're
doing it in such a way
that they can really see that it's safe
right there's nowhere
for them to get to ben used to say like
i'm pinned in a corner right now so i'm
just not going to say anything
and sometimes he was right like there
was really nowhere for him to go
right you had him pit you were you were
going down the road and you're pushing
him you're going to keep going and keep
going until he's up against the wall
and yeah he answers the way you want him
to answer or shout out them by the
juggler
it's a space i struggle with letting go
of the need to be right
yeah i think you wrote that one for me
i've been told i'm like a lawyer in an
argument
me too yeah like we're we're probably
quite similar in conflict so
because no one wins well if you think
about it like this
when you're arguing about something and
there's a saying in the course of
miracles you're never upset for the
reason that you think
so when you're arguing about something
you might think you're arguing about
that specific
occurrence or that event or that
forgetful thing that happened
but really you're arguing about
something much deeper you're arguing
about
some way that your ego has been hurt or
your inner child has felt neglected
in some way right right and so
what i like to think about is how can i
get
out of the head here and into my body so
i can be feeling
so we can be sharing our feelings and
you can't argue with someone's feelings
i mean
you can ben likes to argue with my
feelings
and he's constantly working on that but
reality is is that
feelings don't make sense right they
don't they don't make sense
they're not supposed to they're not
thoughts there's no fact there's no
they're just moving through us they're
what we're feeling
so if you can start to see that even
when your partner is like
doing their thing or you're doing your
thing get to the feeling and just
validate what they're experiencing and
then you're both right
because what you're feeling is valid
right and what
they're experiencing is true and right
it's
all of the story in between that
actually is
just total nonsense their point of
perception our point of perception is
always
real and it's just whether or not we can
get to that place where we go
i just love you yeah right yeah come
back to love and see your innocence
yeah uh replacing criticism with praise
yeah explain what you mean by that this
is a good one i'm actually writing about
this right now because
the other day i posted that i think
yesterday or something and someone
someone said uh well yeah but there's
constructive criticism right and we need
to be able to give our partner
constructive criticism
and i thought hmm no we don't really
because actually
criticism is usually something that we
don't like about the way our partner
behaves
sure we don't like it so it's a
complaint or it's a frustration
because they're not showing up for us in
a way that we want them to
and so underneath that is like a desire
for some need that we have to be met and
so
what if instead of criticizing them
because we want them to be different
which is
all that is no matter how constructive
we frame right you're right
what if we just learned how to praise
our partners for how they show up for us
and then tell them how amazing it feels
when they do
something that we want them to do so
learning how to say
it makes me feel so loved when you
put your phone down and just look me in
the eyes when you speak to me instead of
saying
why are you always on your freaking
phone like you know that that's bad for
you right and it's also
really disrespectful to me and so then
they're gonna go
don't control me don't tell me what to
do sure versus when you put your phone
down and look me in the eyes i just feel
so
seen and so loved like thank you for
giving me that presence
now all of a sudden they're like okay i
get props when i
when i show up like that i think i'm
going to do more of that that felt
really good yeah um
and so i think that actually criticizing
our partner criticizing our partner
doesn't work that well it never works
that well for me with ben
it never works that well for that well
with me no when you criticize
i mean like we can always if we just
take stock in herself and go when i get
criticized i feel
pissed yeah don't feel good i feel
defensive i feel like i need to justify
yeah yeah but replacing it with
something
talk about that oh you know the theory
of you know
talking about or asking for what you
want not what you don't want
yeah so when you say i love it when you
you know
are attentive with me and we can watch
them when we watch a movie and neither
of us are on our phones it just feels so
good and simple and loving and caring
and then you'll get more of the no
phones during the movie that feels
loving and caring instead of like
put your phone down you're always on
your phone and all you're saying is
you're
always on your phone and you're perhaps
going to get more of always on your
phone then exactly
and nobody wants to be controlled nobody
especially men by their women right
right
it's it's it is it's a hormonal dynamic
it's a difference there's a difference
between men and women
um seeing conflict as a gateway to
communication and growth
this is huge right because we can and
i'm guilty of looking at a scenario that
happens and thinking
that that's the that's the justification
or validation that it's not going to
work right
nope guess it's not going to work and so
you then the inner hurt wounded inner
child
will come out and stop my feet and make
the problem worse but
what a beautiful thing so how do you do
that
how do you shift that from looking at a
how do you
how do you recognize a situation that's
difficult and go
let's let's be alchemists here how do we
grow from this the example that i gave
with how ben and i shifted our conflict
style
that's one example it was like okay i'm
going to slow down i'm going to ask
about his experience so when we see
conflict as an opportunity for growth
we bring all these tools in like
curiosity we start to learn about our
partner we start to soften we start to
see oh wow so
they're showing up that way because of
their programming and i'm showing up
that way because of mine
and it's clear that we both have needs
that are asking to be met
in some way right we're looking for some
form of love
and safety so when we start to see the
defense mechanisms and the coping
mechanisms that come up
on both sides as um
sort of like a choppy way of trying to
get love
if we can slow down enough to tune in
with our partner and have
conversations about what is it that you
actually need in order
to feel loved to feel safe to feel seen
we can help each other feel
more safe seen and loved than we ever
have in our entire lives
sure or for the first time for some of
us
and so also conflict is
a an area where we begin to have these
repeating conflicts over and over and
over again throughout our whole lives
and it's sort of a theme that we just go
through where it's almost
like you can date the same person just
in a different body
like a different meat suit every single
time and if you really look at your
relationship patterns
you might start to think oh wow like
that was literally the same
person the same problem same traits same
complaints same frustrations
yeah different meat suit so what
is it that i'm trying to complete what
story am i trying to close here with
that person
you know what is it that i need and so
then we start to see
okay well this is going to keep
happening no matter who i'm with yeah
so i can dump up i can dump this person
and trade them in for the next person
i can go out with someone new i'd get
divorced and get remarried four or five
times
um and i'm gonna keep having that
pattern and so
can we be allies together can we be
partners in our healing
and start to complete that chapter
inside of the relationship
rather than again that blame and that
pushing away yeah
yeah that's a great awesome uh learning
how to hold space with empathy
like you said you know just being able
to allow
and um reflect back mirror the feelings
that they're having
feels a lot like empathy to me to just
say i see you
yeah right because i see you yeah
prioritizing fun
play and laughter and being their friend
and not their opponent mom or dad
you kind of touched on this as well
which is like when you
argue you're not there you're their
opponent then
and that's a dangerous place to be
because you don't
you you're not friends with your
opponent yeah let alone love them
yeah um and then the last one being
you're helping your partner feel safe
seen
understood and loved what are a couple
of the most
the biggest ways that you do that for
ben
[Music]
we we recently started a few days ago we
started this practice actually to rewire
the criticism praise
dynamic so one of his frustrations was
that sometimes he felt criticized by me
and that reminded him of when he was
young and he was always being criticized
and controlled and so one of the gifts
that i could give him
is to not do that and to praise him
instead
and so we agreed that every single night
i'm going to tell him all the things he
did right
and it's been really great i've we felt
so connected
our intimacy and our levels of
connection have just
skyrocketed since doing that um and it
feels so good for me too
so that's one way is like really
actually making a practice out of
praising our partner like
okay i'm gonna sit down and look you in
the eye and you know can you hear my
praise right now for you
and something i appreciate about you is
and just going through that list
and the other ways to make our partners
feel safe and seen and heard and
understood is really
listening to them eye contact being
present
and asking questions just asking them a
question when they share something
like oh what was that like for you or
how did you feel when that happened or
you know what what's one of your dreams
or
whatever so what are the red flags then
the red flags
um like in relationship when we're
dating or in a relationship just what
are the red flags when you're
say you're in a partnership for you know
something over a year and
you know you've been going down the path
and
um there are some dynamics that may show
up that
are red flags and you talk about them
quite a bit yeah yeah
yeah so a caveat is that sometimes a red
flag is really a deal breaker which
means that it's something that's telling
us okay we're really not actually going
to be safe in this relationship
it would be dangerous or really
unhealthy to move forward
and then there are some red flags where
i i feel that you know we all sort of
have the ability to
show up as our lower self in
relationship and that's where we have to
tune into
our boundaries and to our um our our
inner self and say
you know is this a red flag that we're
willing to to lean into and work
with and to heal and reverse this
pattern
or is this something that is a deal
breaker i need to move so i need to move
away from this
emotional manipulation is a really tough
one
because sometimes we're all emotionally
manipulative and we're doing it because
again we want to get those needs met
so i i say a lot of times with red flags
is are you both willing to do something
about this
right right because looking at it from
that growth mindset that
you know we all bring something into our
relationship and that everything can
we can change whatever we put our minds
to but
some of the big ones that need
addressing right these are the red flags
the ones that
are really affecting your mental
well-being yeah
and of course physical we probably don't
even that needs to go unsaid that
you know physical abuse is never okay
and that is like a
you know two red flags for sure but i
think that um
we probably do need to say it because
there are
there's very high amounts high numbers
of what we touched on at the beginning
yeah right like i was in it um
so many people are in abusive situations
and
when we grow up in an abusive
environment we actually don't
know anything else yeah like if we
watched someone be abused or if we were
abused
right there's no foundation like so then
what's the abuse
how do you know when the abuse is
is that that point right because there's
the abuse that that that's like you can
you know justify it perhaps it's not
that
serious um it's a push or a shove or
something like that but um
but what what what point
is it um dangerous you know i think that
if it's gotten
physical at all that's a sign that it's
going to get worse
and so if it's been a push or a shove
like get your butts into some serious
therapy together
immediately and if they're not willing
to do that then
um it's really time to to pivot
because these are all signs that
that person or perhaps both people don't
have control of their
themselves when they're really angry and
that maybe there's a lot that they
haven't dealt with
they're still very angry yeah and a lot
of times this comes out in relationships
and and it can get quite violent and
abusive so
if there's any type of physical boundary
violation
that concerns me a lot john and julie
gottman of the gottman institute
i think it's julie she works a lot with
domestic violence they would be a good
resource for people
um but i would really say just you know
if there's any of that
it's a huge red flag and then you know
there's the classic like gaslighting
where
every time you share a feeling they turn
it back on you or they try to make you
feel guilty and you're never being heard
and you're never
being validated in your emotional
experience
um i'd say that we all do that to each
other in
some shape or form sometimes
but when it's this consistent experience
where like you just can't
you can't ever share your feelings and
and be safe in that
and be validated um that's another red
flag
or another one that i have i often see
is when a person is really talking
really poorly about their ex partners
regardless of if they were really bad
people or not
bad people as in like acting out in
really
unhealthy ways obviously that is valid
and like you're allowed to share your
story and you need
time and space to vent and to be heard
so it's not that you can never speak
negatively but it's when a person is
still
seemingly quite charged around their ex
where they're like
that person was you know we're calling
them names
we're demonizing them in a way and
everything that we say about them
feels like there's a charge there that's
a sign that that person isn't complete
with their ex but it's also a sign that
they haven't taken any responsibility
so there's a lack of self-awareness in
that because if they haven't learned
anything at all if they can't say yeah
that really sucked and everything that
they did was not
okay and this is what i learned about
myself and this is how i learned i was
contributing to that pattern
they're bringing that that same exact
pattern right into relationship with you
so i feel like somebody who can speak
about how they've learned or grown
through their past relationships
no matter what it's a it's a good thing
and if they're
demonizing everyone in their past
they're never responsible for anything
you can bet that they're not going to be
responsible for anything in your
relationship either
yeah well i do believe that we can all
grow and change and
um i believe if we want to
it's available yeah um so
what uh for you
what for you has been your greatest
lesson in life
oh good question my greatest lesson in
life
my greatest lesson in life to date
there's been so many
and i think it stems around love and
connection
like how love and connection really are
the most
important things that we're here to
learn i think it was um
in the tibetan book of the dead i really
love studying death it's kind of strange
but
i feel like a lot of the spiritual
practices that we all do we are in a way
practicing for our death
and um there's some you know buddhist
teachings about when we die we go into
bardo and we're
uh trying to recognize our own light and
they say that when when we die a lot of
people who have near-death experiences
they're told that um
the most important things are that they
learn how to love and that they gather
knowledge or wisdom and
so to me i feel like amidst all of the
material
achievements that we're striving for and
the money and
the status and all of the extraneous
stuff
what's really important at the end of
the day is
that we know ourselves and that we
really know how to love
i really feel that and that we know how
to love ourselves and we know how to
love other people
and if we can remember that every single
person was someone's baby
and that at some point along the way
that they were hurt
then it can change the way that we show
up in the world and if we're all doing
that
it's a much more loving place and i feel
that that would be
such a gift if we could all operate on
that level
so maybe that would be one of the
biggest teachings i've had so far
yeah beautiful well thank you thank you
for
all of your sharing and your
vulnerability and your lessons
um i will continue to be faithful to the
rising woman account your account and
heather's account
you both have them and your husband ben
has an evolving man which should be said
for those who are listening who are men
or if
you're a woman and your partner this
could be a great way
as we spoke about when you guys first
got here like the the language and the
connection
that a man and a man and a woman and a
woman have through language and
experiences and
maybe even just the trustful
trustworthiness of
the gender and the experiences that
happen um
what a what a fantastic platform this
world needs more
more feeling more more
embodying the divine masculine and
feminine within all of us
because we all have that and so i'm
grateful for ben too for having evolving
man and if uh
if you don't follow any of those you
should because they all have such great
information
so thank you yeah thank you yeah he runs
online men's groups as well and we're
going to start doing couples work i
think in
in the next few months you guys also
have um you have partnership workshops
like an eight-week partnership workshop
so heather and i run heal your
relationships and that's through rising
women
and that is for women who want to
unravel their relationship patterns
heal a lot of the stuff that we're
talking about today it's like the
practical exercises and processes for
getting the gold
um learning how to heal the abandonment
wound boundary setting
all of that um and then ben and i don't
have anything
yet we're in the works of putting
together a couple's program we think
we'll probably work with you know 10 or
15 couples at a time we've been taking
our time with that really doing our own
deep work before we're coming out into
the world to teach together
but we're getting ready to do that so
beautiful yeah beautiful thank you for
sharing thanks for having me
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button